good evening and welcome to the Barton
Technology lectures my name is Mark
tribe I'm the director of art and
technology here at the School of the
Arts at the School of the Arts today
technology is at best seen as a way of
solving artistic problems at worst is a
problem to be solved but there's an
entire field of artistic practice that
has been largely unexplored here to date
a field where technologies and the
social political and economic forces
that shape them become themselves
objects of experimental inquiry the
purpose of this lecture series is to
develop a critical understanding of art
and technology as an interdisciplinary
field that has tremendous importance and
relevance to the more traditional
domains of artistic practice that we
sorry that we work with here tonight I'd
like to welcome our second speaker in
the series Chris csikszentmihalyi chris
is the fuku take' assistant professor of
Media Arts and Sciences at the MIT Media
Lab where he directs the computing
culture group a group that does I think
really interesting work we invited Chris
to speak tonight not only because he's a
terrific artist and we'll see some of
his work but also because he has a
particularly sophisticated and informed
perspective on science and technology
and we hope you'll join us for our
upcoming lectures Wednesday March 24th
we'll have Paul Miller also known as DJ
Spooky here in this room unless we
announce a change of venue we're looking
for possibly a different venue for that
with better acoustics Thursday April 8th
manuel de Landa who's a delusion
philosopher just wrote a book that sort
of elucidates Deleuze for scientists and
the last one when Wednesday May 12th
Ricardo Dominguez activists and tactical
media artists so please join me in
welcoming Chris csikszentmihalyi
thanks so much mark
this isn't what I'm going to be talking
about but I will describe it a little
bit it's great to be here to be helping
mark kind of initiate this new program I
first met mark I didn't meet him but he
sent me an email asking if I would be a
West Coast kind of correspondent for
rhizome and I was like I don't think I
have time and so then lev manovich did
it and look what's happened to his
career so I regret that ever since but
uh basically I've ended up now after a
bachelor in fine arts and a Master of
Fine Arts teaching at MIT and running a
research group at the MIT Media Lab and
this is this is what's called a DARPA
quad chart DARPA is the agency the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
administration that funds a lot of kind
of advanced military work the predator
unmanned drones for instance were
developed the internet was developed by
DARPA as well as a way to reduce the
threat to American information systems
in nuclear war so you know if Chicago
and and Toledo were taken out we'd still
be able to route from DC to to Seattle
so DARPA DARPA is consistently doing a
lot of you know very very exciting work
in kind of military technologies and the
the coin of the realm in most science
institutions like the one where I'm
teaching is a DARPA grant because DARPA
grants are notoriously more loose money
than other kinds of grants like National
Science Foundation or some of the other
agencies so when when I had my
presentation to the faculty at our
summer retreat at the Media Lab I was
asked to present my work in the form of
a DARPA quad chart now with an MFA from
UC San Diego you know having been a
terminal artist my whole life I there's
no way that I could ever get a DARPA
grant and especially not after some of
my more recent work that you'll be
seeing later so I thought that was
really funny and of course I've never
had to express my my ideas in a way
like this and like so for instance this
this is the impact quadrant those are
the the new ideas and I was told by
Professor Joe Jacobson he does really
amazing work he he does for instance
these like little collars that you can
fit around your RNA to keep them from
producing protein unless you press a
button in your pocket that's like a
garage door opener in which case the the
collars get bigger and suddenly the
proteins can be created so he's doing
really amazing stuff you know but but so
he said you have to have at least three
completely new ideas and I was like well
you know Joe I mean my education I I
kind of tend to believe that there are
no completely new ideas you know but
rather that there's you know his history
and and you know culture that that helps
determine new ideas and and that these
things are kind of you know I can't
really pull those out and he was like no
no they have to be completely new ideas
and then later like I had done some
stuff down here and and he said oh
that's not good that's the
quantification you know the impacts they
have to be quantifiable you have to make
DARPA promise about quantification that
you meet and I was like I don't know I
don't know any artists who quantify
their work that way you know I just
think it was like no has to be
quantified so this is what I came up
with you know there are no completely
new ideas technology is power we're
researching who uses technology and for
what what is that missing and of course
you know I promise to make the world
120% safer so so that's that's actually
yeah that's yeah I guess that's a pretty
good description of the goal of our
research is to make the world about a
hundred twenty percent safer I'm I'll
show this is kind of one of the I've
done lectures of small sections of my
work in New York before but never at
Columbia and I've never shown some of my
earlier work so I'm going to go back to
about 1992 and show some of the stuff
that I've been doing but basically you
know right now my research group
computing culture is a research group
where we're looking at two areas of
Technology and we're looking
specifically through the focus of what
what are science and engineering
you know there's there's a lot of really
phenomenal empirical work a lot of
really great ethnography of science
right now that are showing that the
traditional stories that scientists have
told people about their work
or that philosophers of science for
instance have have told people about the
work of science are a little bit
misleading they they tend to they tend
to be over simplifications and and you
know part of the two cultures debate
between humanities and Sciences that
those two areas really aren't speaking
so you have scientific explanation of
how science gets done you have sort of
kuhnian models or philosophy of science
on the other side since the late 1970s
there have been some people from the
humanity side who have been doing really
exhaustive ethnographies of science and
that's a you know alternately called
science and technology studies or more
specifically sociology of scientific
knowledge and these are these are fields
to which I've gone to to try to
understand a little bit about how
science and engineering operate and you
know what what becomes really clear is
that through the process of Education
and engineering schools and then
graduate degrees or companies that
engineers work in it's a process of
socialization people like Susan Lee Star
and others have have pointed out that
that process of socialization leads to a
kind of an idea of the world and idea of
what's an interesting problem to solve
and so scientists and engineers just
like artists go through this kind of
socialization process and are more more
likely to be solving particular kinds of
areas building technologies to look at
particular kinds of ideas an example is
that many many artists work with ideas
of surveillance because they're obsessed
with you know Foucault and ideas of
social control technologists aren't
typically they really don't care that
much about surveillance so for them it's
the work fails both on kind of its
rhetorical level but also on the idea of
what's even important in it so when you
see people who are working on
surveillance technologies typically they
don't find surveillance spooky you know
they don't they don't find it unsettling
they don't really mind the idea of
social control and so so this is kind of
the schism that right now in our culture
we have you know a couple of classes of
people trained by education to think
certain ways scientists and engineers
and they more or less have the right to
make technology they are given the
resources the distribution the authority
within culture to make technology now
that one
and always the case I mean technologies
often have been made by workers for
instance and so Marxist labor historians
do really great jobs of showing that a
lot of really important ideas and say
you know 19th century industrial
processes came from workers not
necessarily from a separate class that
were trained to make technologies so a
lot of what we're trying to do in the
computing culture group is to to go back
and try to understand what is the
subculture of science and engineering
and what technologies are they not
building just because they wouldn't find
them interesting and then we try to go
ahead and build those technologies so
we're not really you know building
technologies so much for expression
although that's an important point we're
not building them to make a point
although that is of course very
important all of our technologies do
operate on some kind of rhetorical level
but more importantly we're building
technologies that actually work as you
know proofs of concept as prototypes for
a world that we would rather be kind of
living in or as you'll see for a world
that we would absolutely not want to be
living in so so we kind of go in both
dimensions either building technologies
ahead of DARPA that we wouldn't want to
see exist or building ones that are
never going to get built in any other
way so that's a little bit of what we're
trying to do you know part of the point
of this intervention Langdon winner said
it really well where Langdon winners
Langdon winners an STS guy working at
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute and he
for many many years has been kind of an
ethical voice about technologies he he
talks about how technology's come to us
as black boxes as kind of fully formed
things which we can't really open up we
can't do critiques of technology as well
as we can do critiques of say a text so
in universities around the country we
have many many people are trained to
look at text to analyze them to
understand them to deconstruct them
relatively few people look at
technologies on the same level and so
winner-winner
made a point he was often called a
something of a Luddite because he was
always saying wait a minute you know do
we need to be going down the
technological path that were going down
wait a minute is there an ethical
component to this technology and people
said oh he's just a Luddite he's just
throwing himself on the machine to stop
production and the argument against
winner and other other people like him
was all
if you stop doing new technologies
you're going to be stuck with a status
quo and winner has this great response
which is yeah but if we keep building
technologies without thinking about why
we're building them
we're embodying the status quo in
physical material reality for the next
generation and so his point is that you
have just as much status quo if you
continue to build without thinking so
finding that kind of that third way of
mindful what what filigree calls
critical technical practice is part of a
strategy that myself and a few other
people are involved in so this is the
work from back around 1992 at that point
Slovenia had seceded from Croatia from
Yugoslavia Croatia was going to follow
and you know anyone who knew anything
about that area of the world an area
that my family's from knew that there
was going to be a big war you know that
there was going to be a big and very
dirty war and it was really interesting
because at the time the US government
you know the previous administration
Lawrence Eagleburger had been a major
investor I think Kissinger was also a
major investor in the euro the Yugo
sorry the Yugo this Yugoslavian car and
there were a lot of reasons why the US
government wasn't that interested in
intervening and preventing a war but
what became clear to me is the political
kind of process unfolded was that we
didn't really have any technologies
technologies like governments who are
technologies like international
organizations for preventing war what we
had was things like the UN or you know
the UN perfor which which are there to
prevent you know crimes against humanity
and they actually go in and fight once
the war has started but there wasn't any
kind of interesting way of trying to
tease out the problem about how do you
prevent Serbia from trying to retake
these these areas or how do you try to
negotiate peace you know without the
possibility of war breaking out I
thought that was really funny and so you
know this is kind of early in my career
I was still an undergraduate in the Art
Institute of Chicago and I was like well
maybe I could build a technology you
know that's what we do in our culture we
we build technologies to solve problems
you know your teeth are Brown build a
technology you know so so I thought okay
maybe I can build a technology so this
is this is it it's called hunter hunter
and it has three microphones and sound
takes time to travel so
if you have three microphones and you
make a sound over here it hits the
microphones at different points and with
that you can tell exactly where in 3d
space the sound is coming from so that
was the first step second if the sound
was fairly loud it would sample the
audio pull it kind of out make a digital
recording of the audio and then it would
extract the attack sustain and decay of
the sound - you know if I clap you hear
the initial sound and then then it
gradually kind of fades out and then it
would pass that shape through a pattern
recognition system called a neural
network and the the pattern recognition
system would go and analyze whether or
not the sound was a clap a slap of metal
together or in fact a gunshot and if it
was a gunshot then this is um the
inner-city option it would aim this
small 9-millimeter can and exactly in
the direction where the gunshot had come
from and then fire a bullet in that
direction so the idea of it was sort of
Hammurabi's eye-for-an-eye it was a
little technological instantiation of a
moral principle that if you enact
violence violence will be enacted on you
and so the idea was that you could pair
it you know drop these by parachute all
over Yugoslavia and you know maybe game
parks in Kenya or in fact the
neighborhood in the southside of Chicago
where I was living and it would prevent
you know deaths by gun violence unless
someone had been working on it first and
this was part of a series I did called
tools for a dystopian future I was
coming out of a product design
background I had never really thought of
being an artist but in product design I
had been there for a couple of years
working for some really interesting kind
of proto coms in the early 90s late 80s
and I realized that you know working
with these fortune 50 companies that I
was employed by that the chance of
producing a really interesting
technology was direct you know directly
inverted to the chance of the technology
actually getting out in public and I had
tried in my role as a product designer
several times to produce technologies
that I thought had some like you know
ethical advantage over the rest of the
market or something like this and in
fact the the chance of that actually
getting out in a product where we're
really
reduced compared to another product that
say was smaller or lighter or you know
cost less to produce so so I began to
notice that both with engineering and
product design that relationship that
you're trying to do something that's
innovative and you know ethical you can
do that in very small limited runs and
so if you're good product designer
you're actually accountable to this
whole system and so I'd actually gone
back to arts school because I thought
well that's the place where I can be the
least accountable to anyone you know
it's like the most irresponsible role
you can take in contemporary society but
but the problem with art school is that
there's very little technical education
so I was largely teaching myself how to
do machining this is it kind of looking
around the gallery at people walking by
they would walk really gingerly
so my machining is is crap you know my
electronics are pretty bad you know the
thing couldn't even last you know like
for the length of a four week
installation but I was actually doing it
on my own I was teaching myself
assembler microcontrollers things like
that in an environment largely outside
of classes and you know it's really
great with my contemporary grad students
because now that we're at MIT they can
do everything about 10 times faster than
I could have and that's that's such an
exciting thing resources are really
important in this kind of work and and
having kind of basic tools and getting
enough engineering to be able to
instantiate things technologically of
course the problem with hunter hunter
was that um after I had done this about
a year later I was watching TV CNN has
these little like technology next five
minutes you know and and one of the
reports came on and it was about a
company Oakland you know kind of a high
crime area of Oakland and this company
had been hired by the city to put up
microphones like every city block so
that they could triangulate gunshots and
and I thought that was amazing it was
like you know not long after I'd had my
idea and I thought my idea was so
dystopic right you know but but here
they were doing in Oakland you know the
one advantage of my system is in Oakland
they would send like you know a fat cop
out to shoot you and I thought well at
least I've eliminated the middleman you
know but but it became clear to me and
and Jeff machen told me this in grad
school he said you're not going to
produce anything stranger than what
science is already producing and I
realized at that point that I needed to
understand a lot more about science and
a lot more about kind of the history of
engineering and and you know if I wasn't
gonna have my work trumped by some
startup with a lot more money than me
you know often before I even get the
piece out I would have to understand the
systems that you know I was essentially
in competition with much better so I
started doing historical work and um I
showed hunter hunter in Helsinki and
someone said oh you should if you're
interested in history of Technology you
should really go to tahleen Estonia
because there's a great medical Museum
there and I went and I found some you
know old research some old equipment
from research that was phenomenal like I
just blew my mind and you know I went
back to the US and and started looking
at history of Technology and ended up
going to a couple museums and I started
for a couple of years doing kind of
reanimations of old experiments which
were sort of dried branches on the tree
of science and technology evolution so
so some area that that someone was doing
really great research in but in fact
they hadn't actually gotten out in
contemporary science or technology other
ideas had become more ascendant so this
is an example this is a technology by a
group called American hydropower
Institute which was a sort of a
consortium of hydropower companies in
the American Southwest and these
companies they were building dams the
problem is when you build a dam you
flood all the valleys behind the dam and
in this case the dam was going to cause
the extinction of a species of ant that
only lived in that part of Arizona or
Amiga Micro Nica I think was named I'm
so very small ant and the Endangered
Species Act had just been passed so
Congress was saying no you can't build
the dam so they decided well what if we
can ensure to the US government the EPA
which was a fairly new institution at
that point what if we can ensure that
will keep the ant alive in perpetuity in
an artificial environment and you know
the government said well you know keep
talking so so this was the result of the
research it's this robot and it lives it
lives with the colony of ants and it
essentially replaces you know the
technology of governance by measuring
the ants looking at their population
doing you know the equivalent of a
census by dropping dropping food like
like
we do in you know Central Asia drop food
onto the surface and the ants would come
eat eat the food
hey then you know they would they would
absorb the food at different rates you
know depending on how many there were
and a very simple vision system it had
to be a white background because this is
you know the the 1970s and vision
systems weren't very good at the time a
very simple vision system would look at
kind of the density of the ants make
judgments and at this point you know in
the in the this was I think 1974 at this
point one of the the biggest ethology
sin well I mean in the 20th century guy
named Leo Wilson who is a mer mala gist
who study ants he had these these
equations which he said were true for
species no matter where they lived it
was a very simple one if you look at a
European carpenter and whether it's in
Poland or France or the Ukraine or
wherever they will always have the same
amount of caloric input to how many ants
get killed so where the carpenter ant
can live has to be in a microclimate
where the same number of kind of seeds
are on the ground that the ant can eat
in relation to the same you know the
number of sparrows that are eating the
adds so there's this predator-prey ratio
that EO Wilson said was constant for
species so this was modeled in the robot
so it had you know both the technology
for shaking food out and feeding the
ants but then it exactly the ratio that
sparrows would do it would also pair the
pair of the population so there was this
very bright light up there in a
magnifying glass and it would
occasionally yeah pair pair of the ants
and so so this was their system and they
built it in this great kind of a
geodesic structure that was you know
constantly heated and there was this
video that went along with it in which
these hippies are protesting outside of
a power plant saying you know save the
ants down with progress sort of
Hollywood hippies and then this kind of
warm gray-haired industry representative
comes up and says no no no we're trying
to help the ants not not hurt them this
is a machine for living you know I wish
my mother-in-law had a place to retire
that was this comfortable and in the end
the hippies understand that you know
technological progress is good and the
the installation as I recreated it was
both both the promotional video on some
sides and then also this kind of moving
interactive software that was a
representation of what the robot was
doing at the moment and it looks like
that ant is soon to go you know when
when I was presenting and saw this
Medical Museum in tahleen Estonia I came
across this research which was really
remarkable research because it had this
very unique relationship to researcher
that was happening in the u.s. at the
time this is a this is an example so on
the on the left is a scientist named
Ilya Pro cap off who was reproducing
some experiments that were coming out of
the u.s. in in the early 1960s late
1950s this is a period in in science
there was a kind of a movement called
cybernetics how many of you are familiar
with cybernetics just a little yeah okay
so Norbert Wiener and a couple of other
people had decided that they were
building now technologies essentially
Wiener Wiener was in the army he was
working with systems to help people
shoot down German planes and basically
his his approach was that people weren't
smart enough to do the calculation or
they weren't used to doing a calculation
when you fire bullets by the time they
reached the plane the plane somewhere
else so you actually have to fire ahead
of the plane and it's it's not it's not
an easy thing people weren't trained on
video games at that point so so people
soldiers didn't know how to do it so he
would build mechanical systems which
would watch the speed at which someone
was following the plane guessed by that
how far the plane was away and then
moved the gun based on that and this was
a system where essentially it was a
machine that was sensing information
making some kind of decision and then
outputting physically in the world and
what weiner was struck by when he when
he first had this was that occasionally
the machine would work in which case it
would look kind of like an arm moving
you know and it was really uncanny no
one had ever done this before
the only other servo mechanism that had
ever like become famous was the toilet
so so so he was looking at that and
occasionally if he got the equation
wrong it would sort of palsy it would
overshoot or it would do
that you know you might see in you know
it looked like something that humans
were doing Wiener became very interested
in the idea of communication and control
and how biology and technology could
inform each other and so he started this
kind of movement called cybernetics and
one of the you know a couple people were
working specifically in how nerves
communicate McCulloch and Pitt's are
very famous some neurologists which a
lot of machine learning today is based
on their work but but in in particular
one guy named Frank Rosenblatt was
working on modeling neurons to come up
with a better kind of computer than
anything anyone is thinking of computers
in the 1940s and 50s were serial they
had a central processor they had
information like memory and they would
take the information into the central
processor it would do something really
simple and then it would output but it
was it was entirely based on logic and
math and and what these guys are
noticing is that our brains do
remarkable work remarkable computation
but not using mathematical models but
rather analog kind of you know not
cereal not logic based but analog
representations and what happens is you
have two neurons something positive
happens like endorphin rushes you know
you shoot up and the connections between
the neurons are strengthened and your
chance of shooting up gets much higher
you know so so they were beginning to
model these analog systems of neurons
and they they came up with these things
called perceptrons we're now called
neural networks and they're essentially
analog little computers that can take
some input in analog input make
connections to other other ones like
them and then make some kind of an
output and and Rosenblatt you can still
see us work on Nova every once in a
while those of you who watch PBS and and
it's like this great 1950s documentary
where this British announcer is saying
you know Rosenblatt butts work
successfully reproduces the human brain
you know it's an amazing system and and
and what he's done with it is you know
reproduced our ability to recognize
gender in people that we're talking to
and so basically he came up with a
system that had light inputs and you
could present an image of a face to the
system and it would output whether they
were male or female based on the image
of the face and so he's doing this in
the 1950s really interesting really
promising research but
in 1963 one of my colleagues Marvin
Minsky at MIT and a guy named Seymour
Papert they wrote a book called
perceptrons which proved that these
things didn't work and so in the u.s.
research stopped in neural networks for
about 20 years I didn't start again till
the 1980s and so there was this 20 year
period where based on this one book and
a very convincing set of arguments by
people who are going for DARPA funding
they managed to divert almost all of the
funding towards symbolic logic and
mathematical based artificial
intelligence and you know it's very
interesting it's still something that
rankles a lot of people because in fact
these things work very very well the
book was kind of wrong they
oversimplified the problem I can't say
that to Marvin he's tenured but but but
anyway that's that's kind of the way
most people historically interpret it so
this Russian guy Ilya pro-qadhafi was
doing research in the University of
Moscow and um he didn't have enough
money to buy the Minsky book and so he
didn't know that the science was wrong
and he continued to do the work in
isolation in the Soviet Union and by by
the mid-1960s he had managed to develop
a system which was had far far more
neural no neuronal elements than then
Rosenblatt's did but you know he found
that he could output this analog wave
you know if it was a female face it
would be high if it was a male face over
below but consistently on that analog
wave there was a little bump and he
couldn't figure out what the bump was it
was regard it was there for some men and
some women but not all men not all women
you know the the wave was going low for
male the bump would be in the same place
and so it was this kind of sub harmonic
on the main partial and he was trying to
figure out what does that represent and
you know first he thought well let's see
I mean are all the photographs lit the
same could it be that you know could it
be the haircut you know and so he
gradually you know isolated all of these
potentially missed triggering parameters
and none of them worked and so he then
started asking people questions and he
found that the bump was only there for
members of the Communist Party and so he
became very interested of course is
funding shot through the roof because
the NKVD immediately saw the
applications of this and so so his
research you know continued to get more
and more funding he was new
to tahleen where i saw his work and this
is the recreation I did in 1997 showed
it in Chicago and it was the first time
I used people in my work so I hired
these um Polish women who spoke Russian
and they were wear lab coats and art
viewers would come by unsuspecting and
she would say good they were here for
study and grab you and throw you down in
the chair at which point this machine
would come and look at your face and
then compare it to these faces of nkvd
known criminals I mean the great thing
in the Soviet Union at that point is one
out of every five people was an
informant you know so you had
information on what people you know
we're eating who they were sleeping with
what music they listened to when they
came home you know all these like
incredible granularity of detail and so
when you have you know that big a
population he was able to train the
neural network to you know notice these
incredibly accurate things about people
so of course this is this is a fiction
this piece and the the piece with the
ants are both kind of historical
fictions that I started doing after I
was doing the futurist technologies so I
would I would research some particular
moment in science and engineering find
something that could have almost been
built and then go ahead and build that
and so I would kind of put a new bud on
the end of the street that had dried up
so the stuff about Rosenblatt doing the
gender stuff is real the stuff about
Procope off isn't I didn't mean to
deceive people but but it's so easy
Stanley Milgram pointed this out some
time ago it's so easy if you have some
technology people will just start
believing it and I was presenting these
in art venues I made no claims about
them really you know any more than
eateth Wharton does in a novel you know
but but the credulity was so great that
I was completely unprepared for it in
most cases like when I showed the am
piece you know I was in one of the
videos and and you know no one really
spotted that because they just you know
they saw the the crazy glasses and the
mad scientist and I guess it was
convincing that but you know I asked the
Finns why why did you believe it you
know some of my friends saw it and they
believed it and I said it was so clearly
over-the-top I thought you know why did
you believe in they said well you know
will believe anything from the US so so
this is um this is work that I would do
as historical fictions but you can
actually I think most of them and taken
off by now but on the internet for about
a period of
two or three years there were a bunch of
histories of technology where you would
actually see this stuff inserted and one
time the deutsches hygienist Museum in
Dresden actually wanted to show my work
and we went through the whole process of
the contract and then they sent me a
letter and I realized that they didn't
know that they were fiction's and I
didn't want to get them fired so this is
the last piece that I did in these kind
of historical series called natural
language processor and this this one is
about sort of the relationship of
language and and inculturation and
biology and this is a question that
basically in all of these three pieces
these historical fictions I take an
issue which is a pen historical
scientific issue so the thing about
human faces is something that has come
up many times I mean most of you are
familiar with what's considered really
bad science like phrenology and crania
Skippy these are universally held up as
examples of bad science
in fact if you look at the history it's
very very complicated set of issues and
those Sciences one of the reasons that
phrenology phrenology essentially is the
study of the bumps on your head because
if the brain in fact has areas that that
do certain things which we now believe
in again for a long period of time
people didn't believe in it but but in
the in the you know eight late 18th and
early 19th century it was pretty clear
that if you drove a railroad spike
through someone's head you know this
angle and it took out parts of the brain
they would stop being able to do certain
things and so they said okay let's look
at all the cases and they began to
figure out that you know like over here
your powers of like reasoning and
spatialization so up here is kind of the
important stuff you know for for human
activity back here is your amativeness
which is your love power known you know
and part of the reason they got that is
because cats and apes have very strong
bonobos have very big areas back here so
even you know I know people whose
grandmothers would call them to their to
their you know their chair and feel
their skull and tell them what they were
going to be when they grew up so I mean
these are fairly popular Sciences but
they're discredited now on the other
hand right now there's a huge amount of
research into human faces on attraction
so for instance um all over the world
there are scientists who are studying
what sorts of faces
are attracted to in women many many
studies like this one or two studies
about what faces women are attracted to
and men but but primarily men and women
and and you know it's a very interesting
kind of science because number one it's
largely funded by the cosmetics industry
okay number two it goes back to Francis
Galton who was eugenicist a cousin of
Darwin's who was actually trying to look
for the criminal face so that you could
arrest people based on what they look
like happens all the time you know but
in that case it was based on facial
features and not just color and he was
he was very upset because because when
he averaged all these faces of criminals
the person looked pretty good you know
so so it was it was it something the
frustrated him but all these
contemporary texts go back to him as as
proof that that faces have some kind of
evolutionary component in them right now
there's also another huge science which
some of which has done in my lab called
effective computing which is an attempt
to develop emotional interactions with
computers so the computers can for
instance tell you know like the little
paperclip pops up and you want to kill
it and they it can read that
so the paperclip runs away and hides or
something like this and you know one of
the applications for this that people
always talk about is to have video
content that's edited in real time so
you're watching Titanic
you know there's supposed to be this
heart-rending moment in your kind of
chuckling and so it says I've got a
tough you know tough egg in the house
and so it automatically kind of rillette
it's the video based on what your what
your reactions are so there's all this
kind of stuff of course it's also being
used to predict the success of marriages
to predict liars and you know in
forensic work and criminal law so so the
science is very interesting and it's a
very 8 for me very contestable science
the work on emotions for instance runs
on the premise that there are six basic
universal human emotions and you know as
an artist that's that's a little spooky
because you could just you could you can
imagine what film reviews could just be
reduced to kind of these bar graphs you
know over over time access but um but
more importantly if you look at the
reason that they say that this is true
it's because someone went to New Guinea
in the late 1960s did some really really
bad ethnography you know
that New Guineans have less culture and
civilization than we do so they're
closer to nature so they're good object
to study but then by the end of the book
say but look at these people they're
just like us so they've implanted nature
into us as an object of studies it's a
very kind of bizarre sophisticated
ricourt Oracle strategy by which you can
study people and claim that you're not
actually studying culture or you know
history or Society or language or any of
the other things that we care a lot
about in the humanities so one of the
biggest challenges for for scientists is
to try to understand language because
we're so embedded in language and in
fact no one doesn't speak language
except for a few people who have really
significant diseases and so they're so
far out of the norm that they don't
become good objects of study so in in
one after another kind of attempt for
instance I don't know how many of you
have seen the Jean Pierre garand film
Poteau and Kabongo it's a really great
film from the 1970s and he's another
issue but but the film is great and um
and it's about these two kids who
develop their own language at home and
so right now anywhere in the planet if
you're born deaf mute and a twin
scientists will descend on you from all
corners of the planet and start studying
you and and so that's one of the ways
that you can study language but there
aren't many so this is the installation
as I set it up it's essentially a
robotic bassinet with a ground glass in
which a baby lives and and images are
presented to it from a slide projector
once the slide projects the images these
machines these gigantic tape drives
record what the baby says in response so
they'll they'll record what the baby
says based on the image and at that
point you know you present an image of a
banana the baby makes a noise you have
an idea that they might be talking about
a banana you know or yellow or something
like that and gradually the Machine over
the course of the day would begin to
parse enough information from the
conversation with the baby that it would
be able to try to engage the baby in
conversation the research was eventually
pulled by the human subject board on
campus because the children are
acquiring language slower than they
would have been if they weren't in the
machine all day and you know all they
all they know is that by the end of it
they had found something like 40
different words for milk so
so so those are the kind of the past I
got to Rensselaer Polytechnic and two
things happen so so I left grad school
started teaching in a engineering
university and or an engineering
Institute in upstate New York and for
the first time I was really confronted
with being not having a kind of a home I
was in an art department but it was very
small art department and really all the
people I had to interact with all day
were scientists and engineers and I kind
of realized that I was actually for the
first time you know in a position where
I could make technologies and get them
out in the world you know in a way that
I had some authority now because I was
teaching in an engineering school and so
I thought about well I've got to kind of
it makes sense for me it's sort of my
responsibility now to design
technologies for the contemporary and so
I started thinking about that and at the
same time I had been working so hard on
all these historical you know histories
of technology that that I I kind of felt
like well you know I need to get out of
the library more you know I haven't been
clubbing enough and and you know sure
enough I figured out a way to kind of
combine this kind of interest in the
present there were a lot of technologies
coming out for DJ's that were supposed
to get rid of the problem of vinyl and I
always think that that's really
interesting because there are all these
technologies they're getting rid of
problems like body odor that you didn't
know you had until the technology came
out and and you know one of them is for
me vinyl I mean vinyl is amazing and DJ
DJ culture is a phenomenal kind of
contemporary art that was developed you
know in in you know Brooklyn and the
Bronx and and Jamaica and and you know
for for people in in Japan or California
to be designing these technologies
saying there's something wrong with your
art seems like a really interesting
premise to me and I I thought well you
know what if I were to say that you know
what if I I can't really do something
better than DJing because it's a
complete art work you know it's like
it's like violin concertos you know 300
400 years ago it's perfect it's like
it's the perfect representation of the
culture they come from there's nothing
wrong with that art so I can't really do
something better for DJ's but I could
make a different mistake than what
everyone else is making and say the
problem is in the vinyl it's the DJ's
and so so this was the the DJ I
about sound system which is kind of this
extended project that went on and on and
on for since about 1999 2000 and so the
goal of the project was developed the
first fully robotic kind of DJ it should
be able to scratch slice cut mix and
compete with human DJ's and of course
this this issue about the the problem
being the person is not a new issue
one of one of American labor history's
most famous songs is The Ballad of John
Henry I don't know how many of you know
about about him but he was a freed slave
who was working for the B&O Railroad had
in the 19th century there was a very
common kind of marketing ploy for
selling steam-powered devices and that
was to bring a steam-powered device into
a village and challenged the strongest
man or the strongest ox to a competition
and if in fact if in fact the Machine
won then you could say ah see the
machine is better than a person here and
of course they would manage to hide all
the labor that went into the machine the
factory where people were putting it
together the people who were cutting
down you know the the timber extracting
the coal from the ground to power the
machine you know all these the the
mechanics who fixed it so part of the
way that machines and technology work is
by hiding human labor in a way that you
don't really notice you know the work
that's going on I didn't know how many
of you read the last Harper's but
according to one of the articles there
in the u.s. right now it takes two
calories of gasoline to produce one
calorie of food I mean that's phenomenal
that's the Green Revolution in a
nutshell we're where we've got entire
foreign policy devoted to getting oil so
that we can produce food more
efficiently you know and you know heat
up the planet so so anyway it's it's
kind of an old kind of marketing
strategy to hide this labor in the case
of John Henry if you read the lyrics you
know he was challenged he actually beat
the Machine but he exerted himself so
much in the process that his entrails
spilled to the ground and he lay down
dead and you know isn't that a good kind
of moral for labor so in this case I I
thought I would reproduce the John Henry
kind of experiment by challenging DJ's
to a competition you know and hopefully
killing them in the process and it was a
little bit restaging the deep blue
controversy the idea was to take it to
the DMC competition
and this is um this is sim Tex that I
pulled off of the site of the guy who's
doing kind of the premier checkers
application in the world to be the best
players in real time performance by
combining science and engineering to the
high-performance systems this is kind of
the system I could I'll show some video
in a second but you know basically a lot
of people say why would you do this and
I can only turn to my art and technology
betters likes tell arc you know who says
the body is obsolete and say that this
is a system that can DJ in environments
that are too harsh for human conditions
you know
where's Chernobyl but so our research
continues as of a couple of years ago we
were building the system to listen to a
deejay and then be able to reproduce
their set in real time so this is an
example this is Andy Wong one of the
researchers in my group who developed a
system called Soul Stealer where he was
essentially um let's see if we have
audio
this is him whistling into a microphone
and then this is the system about five
seconds later scratching it
and the warbling is because it was a
warble tone to begin with so it's kind
of a perfect system and so DJ could do a
variety of scratches we could do fast
Fourier transformations on the data and
output a similar scratch using a
proportional integral derivative motor
control loop so anyway of course you
know that was great and I got to go
around you know perform live the style
of the you know international DJ and
really kind of not too important venues
but uh but but it was a great lifestyle
for a while but you know then September
11th happened and you know of course
nothing will ever be the same again
right so um so I felt you know I just
come to MIT and all of a sudden I was in
this place with like much more kind of
you know institutional authority than
RPI and and uh you know within within
weeks of being there people would invite
me to give talks at universities who had
never seen any of my work you know and I
thought wow you know I have such a
responsibility being here I'm speaking
in a way for the entire enterprise of
Science and Technology on the other hand
MIT is something like 85% the funding
comes from defense right you know the
third largest cost object after research
and faculty is Lincoln labs which is a
defense lab that no one's ever you know
been inside of and and you know and and
there are that that's only one of
several defense labs you know around MIT
and you know I hear I'm doing Defense
Advanced Research Project DARPA quad
charts while I'm there you know so I was
like somehow I I don't feel comfortable
being at MIT unless I'm addressing
something of what's going on and in
October 2001 I was just I was looking at
the speed at which the US was going to
war and it really it really bothered me
I mean I was like you know that
afternoon on September 11th I was
flipping channels
you know in a hotel and in Cambridge and
and just looking for some TV station
that seemed to have some degree of
mindfulness about what was going on and
I just couldn't find it and I'm flipping
and I'm flipping and finally I come
across one and and there's this teenager
crying and she says you know I'm just
really worried about what the US is
gonna do you know I'm really worried
that they're gonna overreact and it's
gonna change the US and the whole world
in a negative way and call her crazy but
and and so I'm like wow what channel is
this is the first thing I've seen in
like an hour of flipping and
sure enough it was Canadian Broadcasting
so you know so so I I kind of I kind of
uh I realized I had to do something
about about this and and the speed at
which the US was going to war because I
I understood that you know within a few
days after after 9/11 there was
legislation which ended up getting
passed in Congress mandating that there
be a lot of money put into facial
recognition systems and this was an area
that I'd just been doing a lot of
research in and I knew that facial
recognition systems are awful they're
they're terrible they you know they
don't work very well they have lots of
false positives they have like even more
false than you know negatives so so
there's all these ways in which that was
probably not the best legislation to
pass and so I realized that a lot of the
reason we were going to war so quickly
was just this issue that there's a huge
amount of money and energy pushing the
government towards that I mean you you
spend all this money on defense you're
not gonna not use it it's like having a
you know Ferrari in your driveway so so
so what's the you know what was I going
to do I was going to try to figure out a
system to to keep the u.s. from going to
war and so to do that I attacked like a
good engineer and analyzed the problem
and the problem to me one of the main
problems was that we got out of the war
in Vietnam largely because of the
attempts to bring the war home both in
the media and Martha Rossler and other
people like that so so because of the
images of war in people's living rooms
Americans are pretty good people they
they didn't approve of what the
government was doing and so they forced
a change from the inside now you know
lots of activists noticed this the
Pentagon really noticed it and for the
last you know 20 25 years they've been
working on doing nothing but preventing
Americans from seeing what happens in
war so in in for instance Grenada you
know one of our moments of pride when
journalists were flying there they
forced their airplane down you know in
the first Gulf War there was the you
know press pool system and what I
realized is that in the Gulf War both
the one you know the first and the one
now the other side was much less worried
about journalists but in Afghanistan the
Taliban absolutely didn't want
journalists either so I realized that
this was going to be you know has anyone
seen any images of the war in
Afghanistan what it was happening like
on the New York Times there would be an
image of a Northern Alliance soldier
with some smoke trails in the back and
they would say US bombing happens have
you seen video ok yeah so
so so it's it's you know it was
completely closed down and I was worried
that that would happen I was worried it
would make it possible to get into
another war soon after call me crazy so
so I decided that I would try to solve
this again with the technology and I
designed a war reporter that was
essentially actually when I show this on
video a war reporter which was a robotic
war reporter at the time the US was
saying that they weren't allowing
journalists in because they were
concerned about the journalists safety
so concerned that Donald Rumsfeld said
that if Americans saw wounded
journalists on the battlefield American
soldiers they shouldn't help the
journalist because that wasn't their
responsibility so they were very
concerned about American journalists
safety in fact everyone was concerned
about American journalists safety and so
they said that there was no there was no
no way to allow journalists in let me
just go with this audio for a moment so
basically basically what I did is I came
up with this reporting system and Matt
Mira Paul had wanted to do a story for
the New York Times on the robot DJ and I
said well you know that projects kind of
over but I'm working on something new
and he was like oh what is it and I told
him and he was like how long have you
been working on this I'd had the idea
like three days before I said I was
sometime yeah we're getting close to
being done and so he said you have a
website now it's like yeah we haven't
made it public yet but I can put it up
and so that night I like worked like
crazy and came up with this website and
so you know even though I'm not Dalton
Connally it ended up in the New York
Times with the next day and and and
basically I had to start building the
thing then oh yeah
a really long process this is about half
way you know we were first doing our
laptop based and you know moving of
course we finished it about two two
months after the war ended so we've got
the project mothballed right now for
Korea or you know wherever
somewhere on the axis and and anyway so
the ideas that would have a this became
kind of a media intervention I mean kind
of sort of a media intervention even
though I had really wanted to build the
robot we didn't get to deploy it in time
but so so you know the fun of it was was
the actual media coverage where you know
you'd be talking to journalists and and
I way I kind of sort of channeled noam
chomsky while I was doing these
interviews I I paid a lot of attention
to how he does his interviews and you
know this kind of famous thing where you
have a set of talking points that you
want to deal with one of the talking
points was the predator unmanned aerial
vehicles which at that point we're being
retrofitted with Hellfire missiles and
so they these planes that don't have a
pilot that are flying around giving
really low resolution video I mean
buildings you saw Colin Powell a year
ago the buildings are like this big on
the image and so and then they're making
decisions whether to kill people so I
mean a very famous case was this one
where they followed three people in a
pickup truck who parked near a former
Taliban trading training camp and and
they noticed that one of the people was
unusually tall and so they killed them
and sent in soldiers to get their DNA to
see if they were related to the House of
Saud and sure enough they weren't they
were just getting scrap metal from the
American bombing but I thought that's
really interesting and I've never heard
of before killed them because they're
tall so so I wanted to get out on the
media talking as much about this
relationship because I mean that's a
media issue a question of representation
and you know the army wasn't really
thinking about it that well this is an
America's Army the free video game that
the army released at that point so we
decided that we better put our image
into it so that you know young Americans
who are being trained would would get
used to it not treated so so so going
through this kind of process in the
media was was very you know educational
I can't tell you the number of kind of
phone interviews I'd be doing for radio
and the journalists would say you know
but doesn't that take the human element
out of reportage and I'd say you realize
we're on the phone right now don't you
so this is this is the biggest Muslim
newspaper and the biggest Muslim country
in the world so so
in it I'm being quoted saying you know
in the u.s. we we believe in cotton
gloves warfare style it's a part of our
national policy that American soldiers
shouldn't be killed in a war so we're
essentially coming up with a class
system where one half of the the fight
you know experiences war and kind of
it's it's it's real real aspects of
death and blood and the other half is
you know 17 miles away with a targeting
system and and I think that's what we're
doing and I think it's it's easier to go
back to war now not only because the
media isn't showing people what's going
on but also because soldiers are
increasingly not seeing what's going on
they're not even there when the death
happens when the wedding parties are
being killed by mistake so so this is a
kind of a project that we're continuing
I'm actually you know this was a really
stupid robot it worked rhetorically but
a single landmine would have taken it
out so we're now working on our own
unmanned aerial vehicle called freedom
flies and it's it's there to do more
reporting in areas you know borders and
areas where people aren't allowed to go
so so that's kind of that's that's sort
of been a presentation of my work now of
course what's what's coming up in the
future is I'm running this research
group been doing it for about two years
have some really talented graduate
students and hopefully I'll have more
talented graduate students and what I'm
trying to do is develop a site where
people have access to nanotechnology to
you know quantum computing to all the
things that are happening at the Media
Lab and kind of envision these from the
get-go at a very basic level in a
different different way than they're
being envisioned typically and so I'll
just show let me show one more project
that's been happening since since that
point this is a project called
government information awareness and
this was our kind of second response to
contemporary American politics how many
of you know about a project a government
project called Total Information
Awareness okay that's good that's
actually a lot love Manhattan this is um
this is uh this is a project that is a
dark a hard project so it was getting
about five hundred million dollars a
year minimum they like what they
counted was five million dollars a year
and this is a project to spy on everyone
in the entire world all the time to
monitor all of their electronic
transactions all of their financial
transactions it was very interesting one
of the lucky things for us is that it
was you know basically the Bush
administration was like hmm who can we
hire to do really good science and they
came across Admiral Poindexter the only
known known felon from iran-contra who
was pardoned obviously he doesn't have
much of a military feature his political
future is bust so you know where can he
go but science so he was he was called
on by the administration to run this
incredibly expensive project luckily he
turned out to be such a lightning rod
that um it's been discontinued partly
because of our work partly cause of that
but uh but it was very interesting you
know when you look at the kind of
friends of the court when the Senate was
talking about whether or not to end
funding it was almost entirely computer
science departments who were defending
this project because they realized you
know this is so impossible this can keep
us going for 20-25 years you know I mean
this is like you know such a goal you
know a Holy Grail to be able to like
find out what's relevant from everything
you know so so so is all these computer
science departments saying you know we
want in on it these are these are some
of the images from Total Information
Awareness this is their their first logo
which they were forced to take down from
the internet Sciences power I agree
completely this is another image from
the early website that's a runner and
she's having her medical her travel her
education her communications her
veterinary records I don't know what
that's about and then it's fed into the
cylinder and then her kind of her
quotient of terror comes out of the
bottom and and this is what ti a was
doing and so my student Ryan McKinley he
kind of looked at them he made friends
he's a really good programmer and so he
made friends with some very interesting
people who were actually working for ti
a some computer scientists and figured
out some of how they did their structure
this is still their stuff and he came up
with an alternative and basically his
premise was
take the intelligence of the American
people and and you know everyone has a
neighbor a pharmacist a postman you know
and so so if you could get all of those
people able to inform on government
officials we would be able to have the
resolution of information on government
officials that they would have on us
and so this is open government
information awareness and he came up
with this idea November November a you
know year and several months ago and he
said I want to do something to really
you know kind of help torpedo TIAA cuz
whether or not it it's it's not gonna
come up as a good index for terror we
know that ahead of time because we've
seen lots of projects like it but it is
going to be a great way for the
government to have all sorts of
information like COINTELPRO on people
and reduce civil liberties so he said I
want to do something about this the
great thing about the Media Lab is you
actually can so he goes in there he
works with all these people does all
this programming and comes up with a
system called open gov and and and
basically it does a couple things like
it watches um it watches c-span and
c-span too because of course they're too
boring to watch by a human so so as
these are going on it's going through
the closed captioning and it does you
know it takes photos of the people's
faces so that you can spot them at
airports later and then correlates it
into a database so it's constantly
gathering stuff which you can then also
take a look against the congressional
record because something I didn't know
before the project in the congressional
record which is kind of that you know
the one record of what happens other
than c-span tapes you know Sonny Bono
can stand up well not anymore but he
could stand up and you know for like the
Millennium Copyright Act he would say
they would call on him he would testify
and it's you know testimony would be I
would like to reserve the right to
change my testimony in the printed
record and the the the the Senate chair
will say okay and then he'll sit back
down and then his aides will write like
five or six pages of pithy prose you
know with Michael Eisner talking in one
word when you're and and and and so you
know so so this is kind of the process
of how the congressional record gets
built so now you can correlate that but
also you're building up this facial
database
it also has alerts that run on your
desktop to let you know when someone's
talking and so you can bring in a
real-time stream this is you know kind
of how the vision system works it looks
for incidents of motion
just like a good good killing robot
would so so these are this is an example
of the database that's built up there
are some you know mistakes it's
constantly making mistakes misspellings
and things like that but I'm but he goes
through a lot of kind of text systems
that fix those mistakes this is an
example of the kind of information that
you get to when you follow one of the
links of a politician so he build robots
that crawl through all sorts of NGOs and
watchdog groups and get the information
one of the points of it is that it
should allow you know the the chemists
of you know Antonin Scalia to to be able
to point you know say what Medicaid or
Rush Limbaugh to say what medications
he's on but you don't want to do that by
putting your name on so you can log in
anonymously every piece of information
has a source and a contributor um in
some cases like if I see something New
York Times write it I'll be the source
and they can I'll be the contributor the
source will be the New York Times so you
can watch people who are anonymous but
they build up credibility in the same
way that eBay builds up credibility for
purchases and things like that you can
very quickly kind of go through
political space finding connections
looking for conspiracies and in fact one
of the best things we launched it July
4th of last year our server got crushed
we added a server a day for six days
we're getting something like 10 million
hits a week and an email every 7 seconds
the emails are priceless Ryan's thesis
is online things like because of your
activism you may be targeted for
elimination using directed-energy a
microchip can really hug so we have many
many emails like this but within about
40 minutes no no no within about three
and a half hours we had Georg tenets
home address we had the entire
Department of Justice's internal phone
book so so all sorts of really good
information which point you know we
talked to some people at MIT and we
brought that part of the site down
because we realized we couldn't legally
defend the anonymity of any of the
people submitting information so Ryan is
in California in a huge bus the freedom
bus hacked hacking away on a p2p version
of it that would live internationally
and be able to kind of protect people's
identity so so these are some of the
there's no mention of government
governor Bob Weiss this Weiss
wife cheating graduate of the Bill
Clinton school of ethics is anyway Ryan
you know within nine months had build
this technical system and was in fact on
CNN on Fox you know meeting with West
Boyd from move on I'm kind of doing all
those things just nine months after
having the idea so that's working in the
present is working really well for us
right now let me um let me show a final
final thing oh wow perfect I'm just
about two minutes over and this is kind
of the kind of a little video showing
the most recent research from the fall
of what's happening in the group of all
the different people I should say again
you know what we're trying to look at is
what the success of science and
engineering have occluded and what
technologies aren't being built in that
shadow my own work has been focused a
lot on kind of you know the politics of
science and and and I've talked a lot
about that but in fact a lot of what
science and engineering this are the
poetics of life you know the the
specificity not the generality the
moments the subjectivity not the
empiricism and so several the students
in my group are working on kind of more
poetic technologies that look a little
bit more like what you would can you
know typically consider new media art TV
so um the video starts out with a couple
of things one in particular Kelly Dobson
has been trying to understand the subtle
relationship between technology and
emotions not in trying to analyze
emotions but rather try and understand
why we might love our car or something
like that and so she's been doing a
variety of systems which he's calling
machine therapy where she sits people
down with machines and tries to get them
to empathize with each other and you
know find kind of resonances and and so
this is an example of a machine therapy
session underway with an old mortar and
pestle automatic mortar and pestle it's
a kind of a Sisyphus ian's device that
just you know only achieves release when
you remove it from its task at which
point it becomes very kind of interested
so she's this is kind of the the the
source from which he's doing it Sarah
Higgins who was sitting next to her in
that previous shot and Simon Cecil had
been doing work well they were doing
work during the lead-up to the war in
Iraq in this case they they did a set of
pieces that were based on New York
headlines in this case Bush Street beats
drum for war and so you'd have this
little free-floating toy on a pedestal
you could pick it up take it across the
gallery but if you wounded all of a
sudden these Bombay doors would open
next to you and start dropping and kids
loved it and in fact Fisher Fisher Price
is a sponsor at the lab and they loved
it too this is some Simon cheese all
former former employee of rhizome and uh
now he's with us and he did this project
called haptic opposition he was looking
at the fact that all engineers are
trying to essentially make computers
more compliant more kind of quiet you
know they're supposed to be seen and not
heard you're supposed to be able to get
information quickly from them and so a
variety of people like VNS matrix and
other artists have worked on kind of
unfriendly interfaces in this case in
simon's this it's trying to tell you
something but if you start struggling
with it it'll tell you different things
and eventually give up its assembler
code but it has this incredibly powerful
motor underneath it so it's it's really
fighting and it's actually stronger than
you are so eventually like most
technologies it'll win that's his
girlfriend she's okay
so so this is haptic composition tad
Hirsch is working more on the kind of
activist side and he he's noticed as
many people in sociology have that
levels of pollution and fatality are
much higher in poor neighborhoods than
in rich neighborhoods so he's trying to
come up with a system that can do very
very inexpensive environmental
monitoring of sound pollution gas
pollution things like that
typically neighborhoods don't have
access to that because it's an
incredibly expensive process to be able
to defend it legally but if you have
many distributed sensors that can be
made much cheaper and you essentially
average their outputs and come up with
as statistically significant as an
expensive technology and so this is some
of his work he's going to be continuing
this along with some surveillance
projects through in his PhD he's going
to be trying to build surveillance
models kind of looking at the black
panthers and how in many cases in a
community the police aren't serving your
interests and how can a surveillance
system work and this is of course the
results of Ryan McKinley's project you
know a few you know nine months after he
started at
in the post style of the world the US
government has more power watching the
activity of Americans but now citizens
they have a monitoring service of their
own peculiar graduate student at MIT has
created an internet database that may
help consumers Graham could you a lot of
existing sources of publication and then
and working on ways for citizens to add
more information to that so we we can
really harness the collective knowledge
of the American system it can be very
invasive of the privacy of government
officials aren't you concerned about
doing the government officials what
you're concerned they may be doing to
others we live in the world where lots
of personal information is created about
us credit card numbers or financial
histories and so it's legal to sell it
and secretly behind us it feels like it
must be able to share it publicly hey
did you write for this project I'm
trying to graduate a surprise
okay that's it thanks so much
and then you have to vacate the room so
please keep your questions brief and all
I'll set an example so Chris you you
talked about the artist as the most
irresponsible person in society but
clearly you feel as an artist that you
have a great responsibility
perhaps it's to reverse the asymmetry of
the way in which technologies
particularly media technologies you know
play in society you are at the same time
kind of a rascal in the house of
technology and when you make your work
you have many audiences people like us
but also and there may be some people
like your colleagues at MIT and in this
room but I'm wondering how do you see
your responsibility to change the way
that your colleagues at MIT scientists
and engineers relate to technology it's
a really good question I'm not sure to
be honest that I can I'm trying to
change some things within the Media Lab
itself which was founded as a kind of an
ardent technology lab but um very soon
after the initial faculty were hired
basically in 1985 not a single other
artist or musician was hired from that
original faculty so it went from about
seven people to 33 people all of them
scientists and engineers so the Media
Lab was based on the premise of having
art in the building but it's my office
is in a performance space that they
turned into office blocks so so so that
kind of fell out of the Media Lab at
some point and so I'm trying to change
within there within engineering culture
as a whole I'm trying to do two things
I'm trying to seduce young engineers
with the idea that they can work on you
know sexy projects that that aren't the
kinds that they normally would so for
instance when I hire undergraduate
researchers like juniors or seniors at
MIT every single one that I've hired so
far if they're not in the School of
Architecture so that's you know four
fists of them have worked on DARPA or
NSF sponsored stuff
you're say an arrow Astro you know the
fast new planes or they're all military
technologies so that's the sexy problem
to be working on and so part of what I'm
trying to do is you know by teaching in
engineering schools to intervene early
enough that people can say oh wait you
know there's an alternative to
developing f-15s you know they're really
cool I've had a poster of an f15 in my
bedroom since I was you know in the
seventh grade but um but you know maybe
there's something else that can be done
so some of the fun you know that the
rascally quality is is kind of built in
as a way to be seductive to young
engineers and so that's part of it and
I've corrupted a few in terms of the
overall field I I'm kind of trying to
look at it from the other side too which
is to say that everyone in society has
an investment in the material world
around them you know something that for
instance in in the Danish legal system
there are trials for whether certain
kinds of science research should be done
or not and essentially a lawyer for
using for instance the harvard mouse
donna haraway writes about this the
harvard mouse a mouse that has been
genetically engineered so it'll develop
cancer in every cell of its body by the
time it's a month old when this came to
Denmark they weren't sure if they wanted
to do that I mean you know you've got
this thing that's born to suffer it has
no chance of escaping that fate and and
people were worried about that and so
there is a trial and it actually went in
from the people that doesn't happen in
the US there's no there's very little
kind of public discourse in terms of
technological directions you know after
World War Two The Bulletin of Atomic
Scientists a variety of other systems
were put in place to have ethical
components to science but the bulletin
of Atomic Scientists is over now the
clock has stopped at seven seconds to
midnight or whatever so seven minutes I
think so so you know so how do how do we
develop a kind of a public that is more
able to think about technologies and
when the problems is if you go through a
traditional humanities education you
don't have any clue you know these
things do come to you as closed boxes
that you don't have any look into so
people liking a Natale German Jenko or
Wendy Chun or myself or Simon Penney are
trying to work on ways to develop
humanities based education that includes
a technical component so that the idea
of going ahead and doing
some work and the technology is not that
threatening if you decide you know hey I
want to I want to run something like
move on you have that option you know
right now you have to be part of the San
Francisco technology scene likewise void
is to do it but it would be great if
more people could get invested in that
so so in one hand you're trying to come
up with these kind of rhetorics that
will you know be attractive to engineers
to think about kind of ways for them to
think about what they're doing on the
other hand you you go through and try to
teach people who would normally go
through humanities education you know
some basic skills and and the kind of
sense that these aren't insurmountable
problems when an example in science and
technology studies I'll stop that in
science and technology studies right now
to do khd work you have to work in a lab
like a genetics lab so you have someone
who's never taken any science going into
a genetic lab doing maybe a year and a
half of field work and by the end being
a fully functioning member of the lab
it's not impossible so you know so I
think I think you know and those people
come out being able to understand
science in this really remarkable way so
so likewise I think that humanities
people can actually get involved in some
of these issues in terms of building
stuff so that's sort of what I've been
trying to work on good question yeah
yeah yeah it's totally true I mean I'll
name the biggest one which was BBC you
know they were very very interested in
the system so I mean some of their
journalists had been threatened by US
troops so some of their journalists had
been threatened by US troops had guns
pointed at them so and that's because
they weren't they weren't being embedded
yeah yeah yeah some some have approached
us you know and and that's actually what
we were working with actually at that
point were some independent media in in
Iran and because that was probably the
best way for us to get it in so so but
nothing really came of it because we
were too late
yeah it's just one or two one or two you
know when I was doing the Afghan
explorer you know as I was playing this
tongue-in-cheek Technologist I mean the
interviews that you know if you read an
interview with me I was in character I
mean I was um I was pretending I was
kind of intentionally pre post-colonial
in my attitudes and and so I was often
saying things that were you know
patently offensive as a way to kind of
you know generate more of a story and
also you know they weren't really that
far off I mean I would say things like
well you know really it's not such an
unusual thing engineers at my university
consistently build technologies to go
places that are too dangerous or too far
for them to travel like you know what
the Mars Pathfinder you know so of
course it makes sense that uh that I
would be doing this you know one
advantage is that designing for Mars is
much harder than designing for
Afghanistan there's a lot of roads in
Afghanistan and it's not that
radioactive yet and and so the
journalists would typically say what do
you mean yet and I would say well we're
gonna use depleted uranium you know this
causes you know lots of lots of deaths
in every place that we've fought a war
in the last you know 12 years from radio
radiation poisoning
so so I'd be doing that while I was
doing that Rodney Brooks who's the
director of the MIT AI lab a scientist
who I love his science was developing
robots to go into the caves and Tora
Bora to find bin Laden and right at that
point the DARPA gave a huge kind of
research initiative they offered segways
to any researcher who could train the
Segway to like go a certain number of
blocks enter a building into room and
identify one person in the room you know
with the camera so so so so this this is
what rod Brooks was working on and and
and you know some of my colleagues even
in the lab so you know the MIT
administration was they were you know
they were watching carefully and they
continue to watch carefully so yeah yeah
so but they've been very supportive
overall I mean I haven't felt any
pressure except last question generate
money yeah
I'd say maybe when a green wins the
presidential election so you know I'm
moving to Denmark I don't know I it's it
just seems impossible right now you know
I just I mean the way the country is
going right now you know it's a level of
militarism and technology that we really
haven't seen since the 50s so we're
going in the wrong direction at the
moment